you know
just just the crazy thought to throw out
there a year ago i got myself in trouble
okay i didn't get myself in trouble but
i got you know phil and i were doing a
live and i said what if
what if i run a bodybuilding contest
show but i want the best of the best
show up
first place i give a million bucks okay
second place i give a half a million
bucks
but i want the best of the best to the
best and we sell it on pay-per-view
and it got feel a little bit in trouble
because you're not supposed to be
talking to the guy i mean this you're mr
olympia you're not supposed to do that
but you know what there's something
about the monstro olympia brand that
needs competition
i don't know why i just feel it needs
it needs somebody to ruffle the feathers
a little bit i think it's a little bit
too political
i'd love to see somebody come out there
and steer the pod woman i was doing
bodybuilding interviews for a long time
we may be doing some surprises here soon
i don't know what it is but just
something about wanting to compete with
mr olympia excitement absolutely i don't
know what it is i don't know what it is
and i
by the way i don't even know if there's
a big audience for bodybuilding or not i
don't know if there's a big it is i
think there might be now more than even
before pat
there's a part of me that wants to agree
with you there's a part of me that wants
to believe that there's a part of me
that thinks
you know vegans and all that stuff
there's no world that we're living in
right now that people are like trying to
live real healthy i think there's a
bigger market than you might think can i
ask you a weird question yeah
mr olympia uh-huh how big of a brand is
that
massive massive brand i mean
bodybuilding people okay arnold
lee haney yeah they have footage from
everywhere how many subscribers do you
think mr olympia's youtube channel has
you can't answer this
how many subscribers do you think their
channel guys i said like i said two and
a half million two and a half
uh i'm gonna go man that's tough can you
pull it up worldwide
worldwide their youtube channel yeah i
would say maybe uh maybe four million
four million okay i would have said five
kai can you pull up their youtube
channel right now to
take a look at this you know by the way
maybe help him out a little bit go give
him a subscriber or something [ __ ] i
don't know what they're doing over there
but
okay uh go to mr olympia's youtube
channel okay
here's a brand who the hell is running
this thing that can't even figure out to
get more than 31 000 subscribers
if i'm a if i'm a bodybuilder
representing a brand
like that you guys got to do a better
job marketing you got physiques
you ever see these guys with apps post a
picture 38 000 likes yeah
these guys are posting 48 000 likes how
do you not have a chat
all the footage they own they don't even
know how to market a brand like this
anyways i hope the new guy does
something about it jake would i've heard
good things about him
but uh i think uh i think there needs to
be some kind of a shake up there
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye